joining me now is Charlie Hedges who is
one of the UK's foremost experts on
missing persons uh good of you to take
the time out this Saturday morning to uh
to speak to us Charlie so the police's
main hypothesis then is we were all
heard yesterday is that she uh simply
fell into the water here it was a tragic
accident what's your assessment having
having watched events unfold over the
last eight days or so
that would seem to be the the obvious
thing to work on and obviously important
to eliminate that by doing the searches
if it is not the case
um but they will be looking at other
forms of evidence and information to
look for other lines of inquiry which
has been supported by the Press
statements from the police and so it's a
it's not just about the river but that
seems to be the the most likely scenario
at the moment
yeah there does seem to be a little bit
of frustration amongst the family that
this information was given out by the
police uh yesterday how unusual is it
for uh the investigation team to give a
theory that that isn't backed up by
strong evidence
um unfortunately one of the realities of
working on these cases that we don't
always get that evidence it's slightly
unusual to to release such a strongly
worded statement so early
um but um reading through the detail it
does appear that they are looking at all
sorts of other opportunities and
possibilities for what might have
happened apart from the one they're
particularly working at the moment
yeah missing persons inquiries I do rely
on the Public's help don't they so often
is there a danger that the public may
now think well it was a tragic accident
we can perhaps take our Eye Off the Ball
a little bit we don't need to bother
looking at that dash cam footage or or
whether whatever it might be
I think it is important to keep those
other lines of inquiry open and
encourage the public to look for things
someone might be sitting on information
that they think is unimportant but could
make a significant difference
um so it is it is important to keep that
going and and to look at all of the
opportunities
yeah of course um tell me how it works
when a call initially comes into police
about a missing person what's what's the
immediate assessment that's made
well it has to be assessed against the
uh the information it's already known
and
um the the veracity of the call are
ascertained only to be interviewed to
find out exactly what it is that they
saw uh sadly
um the police will get a number of calls
from people who are fantasizing about
what they might have seen or um think
that they've seen things that aren't
important so it needs to be filtered
through assessed and then move forward
but in a very uh prompt And Timely
Banner
foreign
a week what are the statistics about how
quickly missing persons inquiries are
solved
the vast majority of salt within the
first few hours people tend to go and
then come back and then expect tranche
within the first 24 hours so when it
goes on longer it is uh more concerning
but some go on for many many years
without being resolved as one family I
worked with um Damien Metals he was 16 I
went into the water when he was 16 and
has never been found
yeah really uh really tragic and and the
average demographic of someone who goes
missing uh in the UK
um vast majority of mid-teens
um they unrest at home or in their care
situation go missing very regularly
um the spread across the country is
fairly Broad and most other age groups
are fairly evenly distributed and the
last data we have that the police had in
2021 was the 266 600 plus
calls for assistance in relation to
missing persons
and this case then from from everything
you've said is is pretty unusual
um and the police it almost seems like a
a floundering a little bit at this stage
from all your experience as a police
officer and as an expert in missing
people's inquiries what happens at this
stage on day nine
well it's reviewing the the evidence and
the information that's available making
sure they're covering all of the
relevant
um areas uh reviewing the search
activity to make sure that has been
properly done there's been a huge amount
of effort put into that in a very very
difficult environment incredibly
difficult to search rivers with the
disciplinary certainty and but it's a
review process looking back reflecting
and I'm trying to identify any new lines
of investigation and inquiry and also
being able to fully understand
everything about Nicola her life and
what have you which is difficult for the
family because it needs to be intrusive
but we need to fully understand what's
going on to see if there are any other
reasons why she might have gone missing